à l'Ukraine c'est justement là que se
trouve l'envoyé spéciale de France 24
Gwendoline de Bono bonjour à vous
Gwendoline
vous avez rencontré récemment de
nombreux
ukrainiens et ce qu'ils ont pu vous
donner un peu leur avis sur ce
référendum qui se tient jusqu'à mardi
oui nous avons surtout pu parler à des
personnes qui sont sortis récemment un
de ces territoires
occupés par la Russie ou doivent se
tenir ses référendums notamment des
personnes qui sont sorties de la région
de zaporigia l'une d'entre elles qui a
encore une partie de sa famille là-bas
nous a confirmé que depuis trois jours
et bien les hommes ne sont plus
autorisés à quitter ces territoires
occupés par la Russie pour passer dans
les territoires et bien les territoires
Ukrainiens vous savez il reste encore un
checkpoint un unique checkpoint en
Ukraine ou bien il est possible de
sortir des territoires
occupés pour et bien rejoindre l'Ukraine
les territoires sous contrôle ukrainiens
et bien au niveau de ses barrages russe
depuis trois jours et bien on ne laisse
plus passer les hommes d'après cette
femme que nous avons rencontré la raison
et bien c'est la mobilisation le Kremlin
veut t'enrôler les habitants les hommes
en âge de se battre qui vivent dans ces
territoires
occupés ces territoires qu'ils
contrôlent depuis l'invasion en février
dernier elle elle a passé ce checkpoint
il est un petit peu plus d'une semaine
et demie elle nous raconte que toutes
ces affaires ont été fouillées
toutes les choses qu'il y avait dansé
valises dans tous les dossiers sur son
ordinateur ont été ouverts et ses
référendums d'annexion et bien il ne la
surprennent pas du tout pour elle c'est
une suite logique c'est ce qu'elle nous
dit cette femme qui a vécu cinq mois
sous l'Occupation et qui a vécu cinq
mois à constater l'objectif dit-elle
principale des Russes là-bas qui est
dépassé toute trace de l'État ukrainien
doline de Bono un référendum précipité
qui fait suite aux défaites russes dans
plusieurs zones stratégiques de ces
dernières semaines vous avez justement
rencontré des soldats
Ukrainiens qui ont participé à ces
opérations de reconquête c'est un
reportage que vous signez avec Gulliver
crack